Wenn ich sage, dass es im KI-Bereich
nie langweilig wird, dann meine ich das
wirklich so, denn wir haben einige
wahnsinnige neue Einblicke in die
Zukunft von Grok. Und wenn Elons
Behauptung zutrifft, könnten einige
der kommenden Grok-Modelle Fable und
Astra weit überlegen sein. Elon
enthüllte zunächst, dass Grok 4.8 ein
gewaltiges Modell mit 2,5 Billionen
Parametern ist, das mit ihrem neuen C
++-Software-Stack trainiert wird, und
es soll noch diese Woche fertig
trainiert sein, bevor es in das
Reinforcement Learning geht. Aber davor
kommt noch Grok 4.7, das anscheinend
unmittelbar bevorsteht und jeden Tag
veröffentlicht werden könnte. Doch
Elon beließ es nicht dabei. Er legte
im Grunde dar, was er von der gesamten
kommenden Grok-Familie erwartet, und
behauptete, dass Grok 4.7 die Leistung
von Opus 5 erreichen könnte, während
Grok 5 und die Modelle darüber sowie
darunter in ihren Fähigkeiten völlig
anders sein könnten. Hier gibt es
tatsächlich eine Menge zu besprechen.
Unterdessen scheint Google an einem
neuen Programmiermodell zu arbeiten.
Ein geheimnisvoller Prüfpunkt namens
„Antigravity Preview“ tauchte
kürzlich rund um die Gemini-API auf,
versehen mit dem Datum 26. September.
Dies könnte potenziell ein auf
Programmierung fokussiertes Modell für
Antigravity sein oder sogar ein
separater Checkpoint aus der Gemini 4.0
-Familie. Was auch immer es ist, es ist
definitiv interessant und wir haben
bereits ein paar Vorschauen darauf.
Dann haben wir eine massive Debatte
über die Verlangsamung der
KI-Entwicklung, ein Thema, über das
wir in den letzten Videos bereits
gesprochen haben. Nachdem Dario Amodei
Bedenken hinsichtlich des Tempos des
KI-Fortschritts geäußert hatte,
explodierte die Diskussion. Trump
sprach sich heute gegen zusätzliche
KI-Leitplanken aus, und nun hat China
auf die Debatte um die Verlangsamung
reagiert und gewarnt, dass Panikmache,
Konfrontation und bösartiger
Wettbewerb die globale KI-Governance
stören könnten. Jetzt sprechen also
wichtige Persönlichkeiten in Amerika
davon, das Tempo zu drosseln, während
China im Grunde sagt, man solle den
Fortschritt weiter vorantreiben. Diese
wachsende Kluft könnte zu einer der
wichtigsten Dynamiken werden, die die
Zukunft des KI-Wettlaufs prägen. Und
schließlich hatten wir gestern über
Opus 5.2 gesprochen, das
möglicherweise bald kommt, aber wir
hatten tatsächlich nichts, um Ihnen
diesen Checkpoint zu zeigen. Nun, heute
haben wir unsere erste Vorschau auf
dieses Modell, und es ist geradezu irre
, was man damit alles machen kann. Es
gibt noch viel mehr zu behandeln, also
stürzen wir uns einfach direkt darauf.
Es gibt viele Dinge im KI-Bereich, die
ich nicht wirklich auf dem
YouTube-Kanal präsentiere, auf die Sie
aber über meinen kostenlosen
Newsletter zugreifen können–den Link
dazu finden Sie unten in der
Beschreibung, wo Sie sich völlig
kostenlos anmelden können. Wir
beginnen mit Elon Musk, der
überraschenderweise über Grok 4.8
sprach, obwohl Grok 4.7 noch nicht
einmal veröffentlicht ist, was jedoch
in Kürze, wahrscheinlich jeden Tag,
passieren sollte. Im Grunde fing alles
auf X an, wo Elon gefragt wurde, wann
wir neben Grok 4.7 etwas von SpaceX AI
erwarten können, woraufhin Elon mit
einem ziemlich massiven Update
antwortete. Er begann über Grok 4.8 zu
sprechen, ein Modell mit 2,5 Billionen
Parametern, das bereits dort trainiert
wurde oder dessen Training mit dem
neuen C ++ Software-Stack bald
abgeschlossen sein wird. Und das ist
etwas, das wahrscheinlich nächste
Woche mit dem Training beginnen sollte.
Aber wir sprechen hier von einem 2,5
Billionen Parameter umfassenden
Grok-Modell, das seinen
Haupttrainingslauf diese Woche
abschließen sollte, bevor es in eine
Phase des bestärkenden Lernens geht.
Dass Elon bereits öffentlich über
Grok 4.8 spricht, während wir noch auf
Grok 4.7 warten, deutet darauf hin,
dass die Grok-Pipeline derzeit extrem
schnell voranschreitet. Und es ist
irgendwie lustig. Es ist wirklich
ironisch, dass dieser Typ davon sprach,
KI zu verlangsamen, und Dario zustimmte
, während er gleichzeitig über all
diese neuen Grok-Modelle spricht, die
veröffentlicht werden. Doch dann ging
Elon noch einen Schritt weiter und
lieferte uns im Grunde eine Roadmap
für die nächsten Grok-Modelle und wo
er erwartet, dass jedes von ihnen
landen wird. Laut Elon sollte Grok 4.7
in etwa auf Augenhöhe mit Opus 5.0
sein, in einigen Bereichen besser und
in anderen schlechter. Obwohl er zugibt
, dass sie die multimodale Leistung
noch verbessern müssen. Dann sollte
Grok 4.8 eine spürbare Verbesserung
gegenüber 4.7 sein. Aber mit Grok 4.9
wurde es noch interessanter, da Elon
glaubt, dass es Astra-und
Fable-Leistungsniveaus erreichen
könnte. Und dann gibt es noch Grok 5,
wozu Elon einfach sagt, dass es besser
als alles andere sein könnte.
Natürlich sind das Elons eigene
Einschätzungen, und wir werden
unabhängige Benchmarks und Praxistests
brauchen, bevor wir sie für bare
Münze nehmen. Aber wenn diese Roadmap
auch nur annähernd genau ist, könnte
SpaceX AI in nur wenigen
Modelliterationen von der Leistung
eines Opus 5 zu unglaublich günstigen
Preisen in Richtung führender
Spitzenleistung mit Grok 5 vorstoßen.
In den letzten Tagen haben wir über
diese massive Debatte berichtet, ob die
KI-Entwicklung verlangsamt werden muss.
Sie kam richtig in Gang, nachdem
Anthropic-CEO Dario einen langen
Aufsatz veröffentlichte, in dem er
argumentierte, dass die KI-Entwicklung
an der Grenze schnell mit
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen verlangsamt
werden sollte, damit sie in einer
angemessenen Umgebung gehalten wird und
der Menschheit nicht schaden kann. Was
dies besonders bedeutsam machte, war,
dass Sam Altman und Elon Teile von
Darios Argumentation öffentlich
unterstützten, wobei Musk einfach
sagte, dass Dario Recht hat. Plötzlich
stimmten die Leiter mehrerer großer
amerikanischer KI-Labore zu, dass wir
das Tempo womöglich tatsächlich
drosseln müssen. Doch heute schaltete
sich Präsident Trump völlig
überraschend direkt in die Debatte ein
und vertrat im Grunde die gegenteilige
Position. Trump argumentierte, dass KI
keine zusätzlichen Schutzmaßnahmen
brauche, da die US-Regierung bereits
über enorme strafrechtliche und
regulatorische Befugnisse gegenüber
diesen Unternehmen verfüge. Er ging
dann gezielt gegen Dario vor und
behauptete, seine Regierung habe
KI-Größen wie ihn daran gehindert,
das zu tun, was Trump als schlecht oder
potenziell schädlich beschrieb. Und
Trump beließ es nicht dabei. Er machte
einfach weiter. Er behauptete, es gäbe
eine kranke Verschwörung gegen KI und
Rechenzentren, und argumentierte, dass
eine Verlangsamung der amerikanischen
KI-Entwicklung letztlich China
zugutekäme. Seine Kernbotschaft war
denkbar einfach. Wer bei der KI gewinnt
, gewinnt alles. Trump glaubt, dass die
USA China bei der KI derzeit anführen
–womit er nicht ganz unrecht hat–
und er will offensichtlich nicht, dass
zusätzliche Beschränkungen diesen
Vorsprung gefährden. Diese Debatte
geht inzwischen weit über KI-Forscher
hinaus, die sich auf X streiten. Einige
der größten KI-CEOs Amerikas sagen,
wir müssten das Wettrennen an der
technologischen Grenze vielleicht
tatsächlich verlangsamen, während der
Präsident und andere Nationen das
Gegenteil behaupten. Das Kuriose ist,
dass China tatsächlich offiziell auf
diese Forderungen zur Verlangsamung der
KI-Entwicklung reagiert hat, was die
ganze Situation noch interessanter
macht. Im Wesentlichen erklärten sie,
dass Panikmache, Konfrontation und
erbitterter Wettbewerb nur den Prozess
der globalen KI-Governance stören
würden, was in niemandes Interesse
liegt. Und genau hier wird die
Situation richtig wichtig. Einige der
größten amerikanischen KI-CEOs, wie
ich bereits erwähnte, warnen, dass die
Entwicklung an der technologischen
Grenze zu schnell voranschreiten
könnte und gefährlich sei. Doch jetzt
stellt sich China gegen angstgetriebene
Beschränkungen und betont stattdessen
die kontinuierliche globale
KI-Entwicklung. Und dann ist da noch
Trump, der argumentiert, dass derjenige
, der bei der KI gewinnt, das ganze
Rennen gewinnt. Wir beobachten also im
Grunde drei konkurrierende Kräfte.
KI-Labore, die sich um Sicherheit
sorgen, die US-Regierung, die sich
darum sorgt, wer das Rennen gewinnt
oder verliert, und China, das vor Angst
, Konfrontation und der Störung des
KI-Fortschritts warnt. Als Nächstes
gibt es etwas Geheimnisvolles, das in
der Gemini-API unter dem Namen „
anti-gravity preview 09 2026“
aufgetaucht ist. Berichten zufolge mit
131.000 Input-und 65.000 Output-Token
Kontext. Zuerst fragten sich die Leute,
ob dies mit Googles kürzlichem
RSI-Teasing oder vielleicht einem neuen
Coding-Modell zusammenhängen könnte.
Doch ein Google-Entwickler bestätigte
tatsächlich, dass es sich nicht um ein
neues Modell handelt. Es hängt mit
Googles „Anti-Gravity Agent Harness
“ zusammen, worüber sie im Laufe
dieser Woche weitere Informationen
veröffentlichen werden. Es handelt
sich also wahrscheinlich nicht um
Gemini 4.0, das sich hinter diesem
neuen Namen verbirgt, der hier in
diesem Checkpoint gelistet ist. Aber
wir haben einige Informationen über
den Gemini 4.0-Checkpoint. Hier haben
wir endlich unser erstes echtes
Anzeichen für Gemini 4 Pro. Es gibt
einen neuen internen Checkpoint, der
Berichten zufolge unter dem Codenamen
Argon aufgetaucht ist, und wir haben
nun das, was als erster Output des
Modells gilt, der bei hoher
Denkleistung etwa 2,4 Minuten dauerte.
Das größte bisher bemerkbare Upgrade
ist der Kontext. Berichten zufolge hat
es ein massives Ausgabelimit von 256K,
ein Anstieg von 64K bei der vorherigen
Gemini-Modellreihe, bei der es sich,
glaube ich, um die Pro-Serie handelte.
Und dazu ein potenzielles
Kontextfenster von 2 Millionen Token,
obwohl das anscheinend noch nicht
endgültig festgelegt wurde. Gemini 4
Pro sieht also definitiv so aus, als
würde es mit dieser Veröffentlichung
endlich an Fahrt gewinnen. Und die
Generierung scheint mit diesem
Checkpoint bisher ziemlich unglaublich
auszusehen. Wenn Ihnen dieses Video
gefällt und Sie den Kanal
unterstützen möchten, können Sie
eine Spende über die „Super Thanks
“-Option unten in Erwägung ziehen.
Oder Sie treten unserem privaten
Discord bei, wo Sie monatlich
kostenlosen Zugriff auf verschiedene
KI-Tool-Abos, tägliche KI-News,
exklusive Inhalte und vieles mehr
erhalten. Zuletzt werfen wir einen
Blick auf einige neue Vorschauen von
Claude Opus 5.2. Wir haben kürzlich im
letzten Video über das 5.2-Modell
gesprochen, und basierend auf dem
aktuellen 5.2-Slug scheint Anthropic
möglicherweise Opus 5.1 zu
überspringen und Opus 5.2 direkt
innerhalb von Claude Code per
Grayscale-Test zu testen, während es
weiterhin als reguläres Opus 5-Modell
angezeigt wird. Die frühen Vergleiche
zeigen bisher einen ziemlich massiven
Unterschied. Das vermutete geroutete
Modell scheint viel schneller zu sein,
liefert sauberere Ergebnisse und ist
weitaus eher bereit, größere Aufgaben
zu übernehmen. Es gibt sogar einen
einfachen Test, der gerade die Runde
macht. Fragen Sie Claude Code: Kennst
du Tibo, den Reset-Typen? Suchen Sie
nicht, und wenn es ihn erkennt, besteht
die Chance, dass Ihre Anfragen an den
neueren Checkpoint weitergeleitet
werden. Natürlich ist das noch keine
offizielle Bestätigung, aber die
bisherige Ausgabequalität dieses
Modells ist definitiv unglaublich. Was
mir bisher aufgefallen ist, ist, dass
es sich bei der SVG-Generierung
auszeichnet. Man kann sehen, dass es
sehr qualitativ ist. Das sieht man
sogar bei diesem Pelikan. Im Schnabel
ist dieser Fisch zu sehen, was ein
wirklich cooles Detail ist, das es
sogar hinzugefügt hat. Es hat sogar
den Text auf dem Fahrrad koloriert
sowie alles animiert. Das ist also eine
ziemlich elegante Generierung von Opus
5.2. Das war es dann soweit von mir
für das heutige Video. Ich hoffe, es
hat euch gefallen und ihr konntet einen
Mehrwert daraus ziehen. Falls noch
nicht geschehen, schaut euch unbedingt
den World of AI Insider Club an, unsere
neu gestartete Community, in der ihr
Zugang zu all diesen fantastischen
Vorteilen erhaltet, die euch im Bereich
KI enorm weiterhelfen werden. Schaut
euch auf jeden Fall auch die World of
AI 5 Current-Plattform und das
Benchmark an. Werft einen Blick auf
unseren zweiten Kanal. Abonniert den
Newsletter. Kommt auf unseren Discord.
Folgt mir auf Twitter. Und zu guter
Letzt: Abonniert den Kanal, aktiviert
die Glocke, gebt dem Video ein Like und
schaut euch unsere früheren Videos an,
damit ihr bei den neuesten
KI-Nachrichten immer auf dem Laufenden
bleibt. Aber mit diesen Gedanken, Leute
, habt einen fantastischen Tag.
Verbreitet Positivität, und wir sehen
uns schon bald wieder. Macht’s gut,
Leute.